oui parce que en effet le juge polonais
a dénoncé l'article 1 et l'article 19 du
traité de l'union européenne ça a été
rappelée donc l'article 19 qui traitent
des compétences de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne et l'article 1er qui
me semble fondamental puisque cet
article premier rappelle que l'union
vise le projet européen vise une union
sans cesse plus étroite entre les
peuples d'europe et ce sans cesse plus
étroite qui justifie aux yeux de
certains partisans de la construction
européenne
je dirais d'allant supranationaux le
fait que la commission s'occupe d'un
certain nombre de sujets qui ne veut pas
prévus à l'origine dans les traités et
puis vous avez quand même un article 4
qui fixe des limites à cet article et
l'article 4 rappelle que l'union
européenne respecte les identités
nationales je cite le traité l'article 4
c'est à dire la structure politique et
constitutionnel fondamental des états
membres donc vous avez à la fois un
processus qui justifie des élans supra
nationaux et des limites qui justifie un
certain attachement aux prérogatives
régaliennes et la sûreté des
installations alors face à ces deux
articles qui ont tendance peut-être à
s'opposer je crois qu'il faut trouver un
juste milieu est ce juste milieu me
semble être inscrit dans l'idée même de
subsidiarité comme je l'avais évoqué
[Musique]